make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
okay so we are continuing on with the
boys and in this one we are covering a
story arc of belief and this is probably
one of the coolest story arcs throughout
the entirety of the boys absolutely love
this one because what this does is it
kind of hits it hits home with regards
to like all the various things of autumn
erican does right so initially it picked
up with homeland they're basically
meeting with the representative or I
just really the guy who's running bought
American now uh and ultimately it's just
kinda like okay so like you know here's
the agenda for everything going on with
the believe of it now homeland or hates
this right like he hates the believe
event and up to this point it really
makes sense you know not even so far in
terms of what the believe event is about
but in the sense that homeland just
doesn't like dealing with people right
you just doesn't really like the general
public now of course once starlight
shows up well then it's kind of like
okay you've got to do the believe of him
as well now the reality behind this in
terms of really why the believe event
really exists in the first place is that
it's a christian christian themed event
right it's designed it's high into not
just homeland america but the percentage
of america's population in excess of 65
percent that is historically believed in
christianity and so with that being like
a huge percentage in order to kind of
satisfy that audience base and ensure
that the boat doesn't get rocked too
much any can ensure those sales continue
on the believe event is done to really
basically say that like hey the
superheroes out there they identify with
god's ideology and of course that really
sort of rallies the the the christian
fan base which in turn leads to higher
sales so at the end of the day it's
always about making money but with
starlight given everything misuse
experience right and everything that's
gone down here she doesn't really want
to be a part of it and it's kind of
interesting because what she says was
like i'm not really a person who
identifies with christianity anymore now
in terms of whether or not that's truly
the case i would doubt it i think it's
really more the fact that her faith has
been shaken because of everything that
she's experienced right because
starlight when she was first brought to
us and in the boys comets was really
just kind of like this wide-eyed girl
from Heartland America who didn't really
see the world for what it was I'd say
she's really having more of a crisis of
faith and probably a full-on existential
crisis because she doesn't know where
she fits into all of this and so the
result of that is she basically tells
lavaud american rep i'm not doing this
but again at the end of the day it's yes
you are like this is going to happen
this guy basically pulls the strings and
he knows he has the upper hand on the
superheroes they do what they're told
because if they don't they'll lose this
lifestyle right the money will stop
flowing as well at the end of the day is
one of these things worse like well but
i have to insist though this is not
really in question it's not really a
debatable point if any
thing you telling me that you're not
gonna do it it's just grandstanding
right like it's you following these
higher moral principles or whatever you
want to further refer to it as but like
you're gonna do it right so like let's
just stop let's stop kidding ourselves
and let's do this right even Queen me
says the same thing but when it's one of
these things well you know like gives
the Vaught American Contract under some
kind of review it's basically this guy's
way of saying if you don't do it then we
are gonna pull the plug right but again
it's not in so many words it's not the
super heavy-handed approach and Queen
May basically chimes in and says
essentially he's gonna pull a plug if
you guys don't do this so you guys are
gonna do it you know so it's like it's
one of these things were like we know
this is gonna happen and again it's it's
a pretty cool moment there and so what
this does is it switches over to this
really sensitive moment when it comes to
the homeland and the sense that like a
train is just kind of making his way
through the sevens watchtower and just
here's like some guy crying right and so
like once he goes and basically tracks
it down he ends up finding homeland are
just kind of sitting in this hole crying
to himself and the first thing a train
does is bail basically take off and act
like he didn't see anything
homeland is the most powerful of all the
members of the 7th right and he's got a
pretty short fuse not only that it would
be embarrassing if a train went running
officer hey guys you won't believe what
I saw homeland er was crying in his in
this little hole because he feels like
he's not in control of his own life and
destiny and so on and so forth it'd be
largely humiliating and then homeland er
would probably kill a train right and so
as a result is an a train's best
interest to basically keep his mouth
shut and so from this point we
transition to a conversation between
Huey and Annie and this is actually a
really really cool conversation because
one of the things to keep in mind here
is up to this point Annie doesn't really
know the story of Robin right like she
doesn't really know how deep this goes
with regards to Huey now also keep in
mind like starlight doesn't know what he
does why she doesn't know he's a part of
the boys he's basically just been
telling her this entire time that like
he works for an insurance company and
he's basically sent all over the world
morose and all over these different
locations for insurance claims and
different things like that so on and so
forth which is just kind of a throwaway
thing now it's kind of ironic because
the two of them basically been lying to
each other the entire time like he
realize about the fact that he's working
for the boys and Annie lies about the
fact that she's a superhero and so it's
kind of interesting because Annie pops
up and really really makes a statement
the last time you said you love me was
when we were at Penn Station I told you
I love you this morning and you never
said anything back and that's kind of a
big deal one of the things I've learned
over the years is that for women the
notion of saying like I love you is not
really something that you just sort of a
throw away when that stops happening
when a person stops saying I love you
well then it just starts sending up red
flags right oh my god like this
relationships on his way out the door
and all these different things you know
I think it's for men as well you know
for people in general it's one of these
things where it's like oh god this
relationships coming to an end and so as
a result of that he really kind of jumps
in real quick and says well it's not
because I'm having second thoughts it's
because we're getting really really
serious and the last time that I was in
a relationship as serious as this I lost
the person that I loved
ie Robin and that's when he basically
starts spilling the beans and talking
about everything that's going on with
regards to the fact you know where he
doesn't relie doesn't really seem to
name her directly he goes on to
basically say like there's this woman
that I was in love with and ultimately
you know she was killed by a superhero
and different things like that
essentially everything that we saw
unfold at the very beginning of the
story and it's interesting because what
he's doing is kind of confiding to her
in a way that he hadn't really done
before why not letting her in to this
very sensitive part of his life not only
that like once he starts going through
and naming names what he says is that
like the person that basically killed
his girlfriend was a train now if you
remember back to the very beginning of
the story it wasn't like a train just
ran up on or just punched her really
hard or anything like that she died as
part of collateral damage but it's a
cool thing because when he basically
reveals this Annie begins to kind of
have not really a moment of panic but
she gets sick because a train's one of
the guys in the seven that she
essentially when she became an early
member of the team where she first
joined up and so with that being the
case she does the only thing that she
really feels is the right thing to do
which is to spill the beans and to
basically reveal the fact that she's a
superhero too huge to basically say like
I'm an individual with superpowers now
there is both a kind of a benefit and a
drawback to this the benefit is of
course
Annie's opening up and she's telling you
the truth the drawback to this and
what's kind of ironic about it is she
basically tells huey not knowing that
he's part of the boys you don't know
what these superheroes are like you have
no idea what these guys are like like
all i ever wanted to do was be a
superhero when i was a little kid and in
reality again that's kind of the nature
of the boys landscape is how these kids
are raped right those individuals who
have been exposed to compound be and are
kind of brought up with this ideology
that superheroes are the greatest thing
ever it's almost like a religious cult
believed in this thing right like
believe the superheroes are great
because if you do you could be one of
them too you know that kind of a thing
so it's always been a core part of her
life the results of this is that once
she actually got into it you know as you
said before it proved to be totally
different the problem is that while
she's going through all this and she's
talking about her experiences with
superheroes and while she doesn't really
name names as far as to say like home
landers done this Queen Mavis done that
a train's done this the deep' has done
that well she doesn't really go as far
as to really run these things out and
talk about these various things what
Hugh is picturing in his mind is all the
horrible things that he's seen with the
superhero community
and ultimately a kind of bookends with
this idea that the purpose of the boys
is to either challenge these superheroes
or if it comes down to a knock-down
drag-out fight to kill them and given
the fact that he's killed various
superheroes out there the possibility
exists even if he's not really willing
to recognize it that things could pop
off and he may end up having to fight a
knee and so in this moment of panic he
runs he basically bails out and so then
you kind of get this this a little bit
of a funny moment here where you've got
the female who's hanging out with with
with the Frenchie when they're at the at
the belief event and then really just
their spies right to kind of keep an eye
on things and to see if they can somehow
you know overhear a meeting of the
various superheroes who were there it's
some some tidbit or factoid of
information and as the females walking
around some kid just like snatches up
her sucker right because this kids being
raised by an absentee mom and as a
result of this the female has like this
vision where she goes on a warpath right
like tears the face off this kid so she
helps him to understand his place in the
bigger picture and then just goes on a
warpath destroys the whole city of New
York and it's sitting on like this pile
of bones you know and it's kind of
hilarious because it's like this kid
toad this kid stole my sucker now
everyone's gonna die which of course is
funny because which one of us have not
experienced that moment right like
you're walking along and then you drop
your ice cream cone and you're like
everyone's gonna die this experience is
extreme rage you know or something like
that it's one of these these funny
little moments and so because that
French is like okay so like you need to
back off so we buys all the balloons at
the belief event and then puts the
female in them to keep her in disguise
it's to keep her hidden and then of
course this kind of sins are flowing
along and and carries her along the way
so what this does is this jumps over to
basically the sidekick 12 and oh father
now of course again this is not like
some group that exists out there and Oh
father just kind of hey like you know
where though we're like a religious
superhero team they are but again
they're bought American guys but
somebody that I want you to notice here
is that when it comes to Oh father he's
very much aware of everything that goes
on but it's kind of ironic right because
with almost any kind of religious system
the religion is where the money is and
so that's when it comes to that then
when it comes to the character of Oh
father he's kind of got the perfect kid
so long as he keeps people believing in
the correlation between superheroes and
God then like the religious money keeps
flowing and then in turn bought American
keeps making that money right so at the
end of the day like what he's talking to
homeland err this is kind of like yeah
man like homeland asks a question like
do you really believe like how do you
feel about this whole thing with mod
American trying to position superheroes
you know in a spot where they can
basically go on and be part of the
defense system of the United States and
the response of
fathers like you really believe that's
gonna like that's not gonna happen
that's never gonna happen right like
that's that's like literally like bought
American backed the wrong horse right
like appointing a goofball like Vic the
veep to be the one to carry out their
goals and so on and so what they they
back the wrong candidate back the wrong
horse bought Americans going about it
all the wrong way this basically shows
that Oh father is just kind of like I
just do my job right like it's best
that's really what it is right he's a
guy that just clocks in at 8:00 a.m.
clocks out at 4:30 p.m. and he's done
and that's basically it right like his
his day is over and that's essentially
he doesn't really care about the
politics of it all he doesn't really
care about American he just collects his
check and goes home and plays his part
just like everybody else and it's kind
of interesting you know it's it's kind
of hard to explain you know in terms of
how that feels in comparison to
everything else and maybe it's just the
the differences between the two the
DeMars was between homeland or in so far
he's up there in the ivory tower as part
of the seven and then you've got you
know Oh father who's down there on the
ground with the various superheroes and
I was also kind of ironic too because
given his ties to bought American and
given how believe is kind of this
eccentric event that takes place every
year with regards to Christianity and
and superheroes that Oh father really
kind of doesn't really have his hands in
everything so much as he knows everybody
and that's really what Homeland er asked
you know like if an event quote-unquote
were to take place that would force the
hand of the government to basically sign
with us right like if things popped off
more or less how many people do you
think we'd be able to get to our side
and it's kind of one of these things
worse like are you talking about the
idea of like rising up against the
government or against the people or like
what is this right because Paul Landers
being very very cloak-and-dagger right
he's not really spilling the beans here
and so you know father kind of picking
up on what homelands laying down is like
well maybe like 60 or 65% and from
homeland or it's like those odds are
good enough so what he basically says is
like bring everybody together you know
once this whole believe event is done
gather all the people that you think
will be on our side and bring them
together right like like bring them to
our cause and we can go from there
the other part of this is that once a
knee actually gets up on stage and
starts talking you really kind of a
spouse is this ideology that like God is
the only way and almost kinda like this
intolerance anything that's not a belief
in God is inherently wrong you know this
sort of intolerant perspective begins to
really kind of draw the attention of Oh
father at homeland er insofar as Oh
father asked like what's the deal with
this chick like what's what's going on
with her and home Landers like well
she's a believer she believes in the
idea of superheroes and she believes in
goodness and all I kind of get you know
all I kind of stuff like she's really
just wide-eyed and and really kind of
naive in a lot of different ways at
least she was
she's gained a lot of experience from
everything that's going on here but it's
kind of interesting because one of the
things they kind of agree on is she
can't really be trusted right like
starlight can't really be trusted as a
person who would rally to the side of
the superhero community because she
doesn't want to be part of the superhero
community and this really sort of hits
home when you have heard talking
directly to homeland it's kind of
interesting because they sort of share
this moment of solidarity right like
this moment of her basically confiding
in him and they're the common ground of
course is in their disdain for Vaud
American right because what America is
one who pulls the strings and the
superheros not really in control of
their own lives and it's kind of crazy
because when that goes on it's just kind
of like homeland are saying like I can
appreciate the way that you stood up to
Vaught American and in starlights like
well I mean doesn't really matter
because it ended you know it resulted to
me be here but home liners like that's
not the point the point isn't whether or
not you had to do it
the point is that you basically showed
that American we're not here to do
everything that you tell us to we can
say no sometimes and that's kind of a
funny thing there because the reality of
these superheroes given the power that
they have is that if they chose to
conquer the United States who's gonna
stop them right the military's not gonna
be able to stop and bought American
can't stop them right like nobody could
stop them they'd stop themselves and
that's basically it
but it's kind of funny because in
starlight basically says well you know
I'm considering giving up on the Seven
and basically quitting the superhero
team and going about and doing my own
thing and then homeland or snaps back to
being the dick that we all know he is
and he says what you're gonna do that
after all the hard work you put in
getting onto the team in the first place
we're just kind of like well screw you
then if that's how you're gonna be hey
we're just kind of like wouldn't you if
that's how you're gonna be and she
basically just storms off and leaves and
so just kinda like what I am you know
like this guy's a dick and so following
that what you basically get is this this
sort of coming together between Huey and
and Billy butcher in a way that wasn't
really there before right because he
basically goes through and just starts
spilling the beans to Billy butcher and
saying like here's everything that's
going on with with me and Annie I let
you know with me and starlight and is
one of these things where Billy butcher
kind of seems to have a lot of the
answers or seems to know what's going on
but does it have all the details and
healy opening up is really designed to
say hey look if I'm gonna be part of the
boys then I'm gonna I'm gonna tell you
everything that's going on right to kind
of try to build this this trust between
the two of us are standing along those
lines and of course he goes through and
starts saying like this is how long
we've been together and this is this is
how we met and all that kind of stuff so
basically everything that we've seen in
the story so far but then Billy butcher
in turn you know where he kind of has
this moment where he believes that Billy
doesn't trust him anymore
then Billy basically says no here's
what's going on well like here's here's
my end of the bargain by the you here's
me basically telling you
what you didn't know before and what he
says is that when when the question was
kind of asked in the beginning how do we
have all this secret information and all
all this all this stuff on all these
various superheroes how are we able to
monitor the the seven the way that we
are billy butchers like its Queen made
Queen Maeve is the Spy that we have
inside the seventh which is a massive
revelation because of the questions like
how did they manage to get their hands
on Queen Mays and so what we end up
learning is that at some point in the
past when Queen may first join the team
she basically kind of defected to a
degree and the reason why was because if
you guys remember the legend was an
employee of Vaud American insofar as he
basically worked for victory comics I
work for the direct arm and then
eventually basically parted ways with
with Maude American and became an
information broker of sorts working
directly with the boys themselves after
becoming the Oh more or less an enemy of
Vaud American proper and so because of
that Queen Maeve you know having had a
close tie to the legend when he worked
it when he worked at bought American as
somebody she could confide in basically
came out and said I want to see this
seven taken down it wasn't done in so
many words right it wasn't like she
showed up with a bullhorn it was like I
want to kill homeland er and a deep and
a jury and all these guys it wasn't
really anything like that it was like
like just kind of looking at her it was
okay she wants these guys to suffer but
the real question wasn't really answered
in terms of why what happened that led
her to want to take these guys out and
so as time progressed and as time began
to pass really butcher using his contact
using his information information that
was given to him by the legend
information given to him by Mallory
basically reveals that like at some
point along a line Queen Maeve ended up
having sex like which we kind of knew
but basically these sexual escapades
were taken were captured in the form of
photographs and then we're like
dispersed out for the guys I bought
American to see and so because that she
felt humiliated and felt embarrassed and
wanted to enact her revenge accordingly
I said what is up going on here is Billy
butcher basically sits huy down this was
okay man like I'm gonna go get some
Chinese food continue what you were
doing monitoring the tape see if we can
find any information or anything like
that and it's not really an innocuous
thing right like it's a nefarious thing
because what Billy had done is he had
sat huy down to basically monitor to the
tape without he'll be really knowing it
at the time to look to watch the tape
we're starlight basically ends up giving
to the guys that she gave him to when
she first joined the seven and Huey
watching all this go down is absolutely
destroyed because as soon as that
happens of course the Oh Billy butcher
comes back from getting Chinese and it
just you know we're here we asked have
you seen that Billy butcher's like yeah
I basically have now understand it's not
Billy butcher doing it for the sake of
just being me
is Billy what you're doing it for the
sake of showing you a showing Huey the
kind of person that he's dealing with or
at least the kind of person Billy
butcher thinks Huey's dealing with
because remember from Billy butcher's
perspective superheroes cannot be
trusted they cannot be trusted and they
should not be trusted ever ever ever
they're inherently bad people even if
they started out good they always end up
becoming bad absolute power corrupts
absolutely
that's the stance of Billy butcher with
regards to the superhero community in
the boys comics and so what he says is
like the reality of this is have you
ever considered that she's just laughing
at you under what circumstance was she
have ever gotten with you previously
she's getting with you because one you
know she doesn't believe she has any
other opportunities or two she's damaged
goods she's screwed up if she was a
healthy functioning normal human being
she would never be with you and it was
just kind of like that's kind of screwed
up man like that's kind of a dick thing
to say
right but at the same time is basically
Billy butchers perspective he's not
coming from a place of vindictiveness
it's what he genuinely believes and so
it's like once she basically got up to
the seventh once she started doing your
own thing then you know her being
screwed up is just kind of looking at
looking at a guy like you and just
saying well you're just there right so
her being with you is just satisfying
some itch she needs to scratch but
that's basically it like you're not
really anything to hurt and don't let
yourself believe that you are and so
this really hits huy home now the
reality is it hits huy heart because
he's in a vulnerable position and that's
where things like that come into play
right as it's using that kind of line of
logic using that that sort of distorted
logic and then using it on a person in a
vulnerable position of course is going
to affect him in any normal circumstance
he wouldn't really believe it or he may
incorporate it and then not necessarily
run with it and apply to everything else
and then drawers own conclusions but
being in this emotionally crushed state
everything impacts him psychologically
and so because of that the Huey
basically ends up running off to cry and
then when he comes back you know he's
basically like okay I'm gonna go take
off for a minute now of course believe
what your knows the Huey's gonna go
confront any of that well he knows he's
gonna go confront Starlite about it
somebody tells a thousand is don't tell
her how it was that we saw this if Huey
goes and confronts her about it and just
starts popping off at the mouth and then
in turn starlight gets angry well then
then the question becomes how in the
world did they know that this was going
on
then it raises the question of are they
watching us and if they are watching us
then one where are these cameras - who
planted them there and three how much do
they know right so basically it would
blow open the boys ability to monitor
the seven because it would it would
essentially destroy their intelligence
gathering as it exists up to this point
it would it would ruin
be much everything and so as a result of
that you end up kind of jumping back to
the end of the believe of it and at the
end of this event it was basically this
idea that there was going to be a raffle
and those individuals who won or at
least the the particular family who one
would get dinner with homeland and so of
course the family who won is a Mueller
Family from Larchmont New York I think
it's how you pronounce that this was
come on yeah you know these guys win
it's like you know hey everybody thanks
for coming out this was an awesome
believe event you know thanks for being
part of this and so basically like you
know as they begin to take off French he
begins to have this realization of
what's going on here that it's like like
yes they're all leading like yes they're
all flying into the air but homeland er
keeps flying a higher and higher that
the realities at homeland should be
flying to a particular direction given
that he's flying a car these are people
who are not acclimated for like
superhero antics you know their bodies
aren't super durable they're like flying
them directly up into the sky like that
home lander is going to do something and
so what you do is you jump directly back
to human and Annie and everything pops
off the first thing he does is cholera
and then after that just starts laying
in door and all he's doing is taking
everything to Billy butcher told him
combining it with all these negative
emotions and pouring it out directly on
a knee there's not really one ounce of
rational thought that's coming out of
Huey at the moment it's just anger and
and hurt that's really all it is because
what he does is he looks at her and says
like he thinks about what Billy butcher
says and that she never would have had
anything to do with him under any normal
circumstance that all he's experienced
is heartbreak and suffering and he's
like yeah like you are screwed up you
are damaged goods like you're a messed
up person all you've been doing is
laughing at me behind my back I don't
matter to you like I'm not relevant to
you and there's and where Annie tries to
stop and explain and say look it's not
like that it happened before before we
met and where she is right in so far is
like one it did happen before they met
and to like it's something that she's
been struggling with the other part of
the reality here is it's a choice that
Annie made she could either engage in
some lewd sexual activities and achieve
her dream or she could just go back to
not not engaging in those those lewd
activities and when that that moral
question was presented to her she chose
to basically take the take the path of
engaging in lewd sexual activities she
made that choice and so because she made
that choice what it does is it reflects
what really matters most to her for
moral viewpoints or being a superhero
and she chose to be a superhero her
moral viewpoints didn't really seem to
matter and so because of that it really
does shine her in a negative light and
huy recognizing that seeing how that
tape unfolded looks at her and really
kind of again builds on what billy
butcher said her or so they recalled a
billion butcher said she's nothing like
what he thought she was she's a totally
different
now that's where Huey's wrong right
because Huey like the the person that he
spent his time with is a true person the
reality is that when it comes to any
kind of relationship yes you have the
honeymoon phase yes you have that phase
where there's the person as they appear
to be and then as that honeymoon phase
begins to go away the person as they
really are begins to manifest it begins
to show up and you see them for the kind
of person they are the test of any real
relationship of any tried and true
relationship this designed lasts any
real measure of time is once you move
away from the illusion of who you think
a person is and you look at for look at
them for who they truly are or you still
in love with them then the relationship
is solid and strong but if after that
illusion basically begins that after
it's removed and you look in that person
for who they are and you don't feel like
you're in love with them anymore then
you were in love with the idea of them
that's the truth of it and when you when
Huey looks at that and says like yes
like when he previously looked at that
and said I look at her for who she was
with her being a superhero that doesn't
really change anything this and Huey's
mind changes everything because what it
says is the secret she was hiding wasn't
just that she was a superhero this
secret she's hiding is that she wasn't
like her moral compass is really matter
it's not really relevant and so it's
just pain and suffering and hurt and so
because of that he basically kind of
kisses her out and then ends the
relationship and walks off basically
says like we're not together anymore
like we're done here now the reality and
one of the funny things about this is
Huey sort of uses to himself and is like
yes he knows he's making the wrong
choice right he knows he's making the
wrong decision here and so because that
he just kind of continues on he sticks
to his guns and keeps on leaving and
leaves starlight in this emotionally
crushed position which is ultimately I
imagined going to turn into rage not
only that what you do is you jump back
to home Lander and homeland are
basically flying the Mueller family
through the sky well they're like
screaming every like please like take us
back down to the ground like we
appreciate the sightseeing tour but like
we're freezing up here and all that kind
of stuff homeland is just kind of like
everything that you know about belief is
utter nonsense everything you know about
superheroes is utter nonsense none of
this stuff is real none of this stuff is
what you think it is you have this
perception of superheroes that we do
great things and we act in accordance
and then all this kind of super these
superhero antics and so on and so forth
but none of its real right it's all a
bunch of [ __ ] that's really all it
is it's designed to make money and it's
designed to scam idiots like you out of
your money and you're stupid enough to
fall for it because you're not really
reading between the lines you're just
kind of going with the world the way you
would hope it would be not the way that
it really is and so what he does is he
says if you're looking to the sky for
God up there listening there isn't one
the only man in the sky is
meet and he basically drops the car like
literally just drops a family to their
desk and we're all the other supers you
were following him basically show up and
and they follow suit then he says let's
talk with that being said guys we're
gonna bring this video to an end if you
are new here to come this explain make
sure you guys are the sub button to
become part of the Rob pork you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop on
like and yeah I will catch you all later
peace we've got some new patrons in our
top tiers over on patreon comm slash
comments explained I want to give a
shout out to Jason see Austin s Austin H
Phillip and Austin B as well as Steven Z
Eagle F Joey M and Jeff are as well as
Genesis 916 as always we just usually
keep the last name to it initial it
helps you guys to maintain your
anonymity some of you guys are expressed
concerned about having like your first
and last name thrown out there for the
world to see I do not blame you for you
guys who have joined up as part of our
patreon tiers that are eligible for rob
court honor guard rings those whose
rings have been sent out you should
already have them if you're a new person
who just joined up and you've been part
of this to here for a month your ring
will be mailed out to you so I want to
say thank you guys for being patrons
[Music]
[Music]